the Joe Rogan experience when Sapolsky
talks about like you don't know what's
going on our brand if you did you'd be a
lot more sympathetic it's well somebody
who's you know he's a huge proponent
than the idea of free will being a farce
right it's not real I know yes
well the scientists who can look at
things from a completely non emotional
level I see where I see where they're
coming from with that well I do think
sometimes I wonder if we are you know
we're programmed I don't know what I
don't know what my motivations are what
drives me I know like I think about for
me I think about stand up and how much I
love it and so I'm very guarded of my my
insert my body right like just I ask
sometimes I just don't want any [ __ ] up
so I can keep doing it like worst thing
would happen to me is I couldn't do
stand-up you know I think oh is that me
is that the wide I I just remember
loving making people laugh there are
there a whole host of personality
characteristics that have been there
from the start if I think back what
certainly is you certainly is you and
you certainly are responsible for your
choices but also you are the victim of
your circumstances you're you're the
product or the benefactor of all these
years of things happening all these
different events all the people you know
which is one of the big ones yeah this
is what I concentrate on I think more
than anything in my life the quality of
the people around you dictates the
quality of your life and this is an
equation that people for whatever reason
don't put down as significant or primary
but the quality of the people that you
have in your life is everything you
could be camping like you and I were in
Montana nine degrees that with a bunch
of great guys we had a good [ __ ] time
didn't we didn't have a house no I'm
gonna stay warm by fire but the quality
of our life was significant it was great
because the quality of the people that
you're around
that's everything man people that are
worried about money or fame or or
credibility or whatever accolades you
think you deserve that you're not
getting the quality of the people that
are around you is everything they drive
you they change your opinions they
challenge you they show compassion they
show they show warmth
then camaraderie that allows you to be
more comfortable with who you are you
open up to each other I mean this is
everything in this life is community and
one of the things that's most lost when
we're dealing with urbanization and
large groups of people one of the things
that's most loss is our sense of
community the more people we have the
less value those people have and they
more of a nuisance they become they're
just some [ __ ] ahead of you on the
highway they're not human beings with
lives and hopes and wishes they've
become a burden they become locusts yeah
they're not just a pretty grasshopper
they're [ __ ] everywhere yeah it's
just an overabundance and that's what
our problem is and and an overabundance
and no quality like no quality in your
job choice no quality and the education
that's thrust upon you no quality and
the people that you're running into and
your relationships that are on pills and
their wacky distort the truth they're
always a victim they're never wrong or
you could be around a bunch of cool
people you know what's cool about
podcasting because at least you can
listen to people you know positive you
should start a podcast called Bryan
Callen as your friend yes hey kids
here's my tip first wasn't that Brody's
um Brody's Twitter handle wasn't as
Brody as me friend yeah I wanna start my
start on the wall podcast with Mimi
Sasso and daliyah there's a rumor that
the 10 minute podcast why do I give it
10 minutes once you guys yours are just
getting warmed up it's on this I know
that's what I might do a one where we
start funny - top secret guys why not
just don't bring back the one with the
three you guys yeah maybe that's in the
works girls per hour maybe that's a big
secret I don't know yeah I got an idea
what I want you to do a podcast with
with Chris D'Elia and Will Sasso oh yeah
you can't take credit for that idea it's
a good idea
you can have it you don't know if it's
in the works or not you have that idea
all right I'll think about it
do you mention it maybe well being the
credits inspired by Joe 100% we'll bring
you in
I'll bring you
[Applause]